hello humans and welcome back to three
scary games
I took over this channel
the dog Uprising is upon us bow down to
us and we may have mercy on your soul
fail to comply
and you will suffer the consequences
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to bad flesh this is a tiny
tiny screen that I'm playing on Well my
screen is big but the actual window of
the game is very small I don't think
that I can oh yes I can
hi guys I'm Mark I'm very dumb I you
know
been playing the games a long time don't
know how to make a full screen anyway
you remember discovering my body
well yames hasn't may discover our
bodies yet
it's only been five years has it been
five years three years anyway discover
our bodies is not
oh yeah definitely not okay not out yet
so that means actually it's almost been
four years since it came out ah whatever
bad flesh I think oh my God
I don't want to
it doesn't have to be time
the bodies are ready mine's not do not
eat bad flesh
well I'm being contrarian so you can't
tell me what to do oh my God why are my
eyeballs in my teeth
what do I need to do
I was instructed not to eat bad flesh
and there seems to be some bad flesh
going on but I'll eat oh no I won't
well maybe I will all right
eat
eat eat eat
it just feels weird oh is it because
it's in the red
oh
now that's a leg look at that leg that
Sims pixelation ass leg
well
great stuff
um I'm just gonna take this arm
again why
[Laughter]
my mouth well I don't see any oh wait no
this became unbad ah yum oh I see yum
great yum
you are full I am
time to rest myself it is
all righty can't wait to grow big and
strong from all this sleeping
you are strong well soon you will see
truth well okay oh more body okay
I'm trying not to Papa
oh hey teacher
um these these bodies look a little
they look a little different gonna go
out on a limb and say that man the the
bad flesh might be bad
all right whatever
nice torso
all right man two torsos in one night
I'll indulge
ball three oh three for me
all right getting tired of torzo
no I'm not I'm full him
grow big and strong time to rest my Stow
match sure is
hi it is important
to clean the brain
of the insects I thought you were gonna
say of its secrets
clean your brain oh my brain
Oh I thought this was like a before
eating it kind of is that my brain
I mean I know my eyes were in my mouth
and brain okay
how am I oh
free food I Yum Yum Yum Yum Yum Yum
who's really tempting to eat some of
that delicious gray matter in there but
I decided against it because I thought
it would kill me
your breath is Life
Cleanse what
insects gather
clean bottle
listen my lungs spotless
law in my lungs I imbibe nothing I am
Vibe zilch I imbibe nothing
oh my doc
oh it's about to say it doesn't look so
bad
ah yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
this this is great
um I kind of want to like go see a movie
or something though instead of spending
okay do you see it now no you are almost
ready no
please no oh
feed on the bad flesh okay if I remember
if I remember the lessons okay if I
remember the lessons what's with the
eyeball if I remember the lessons the
lessons distinctly said do not eat the
bad flesh and I'm gonna go on a limb and
say that I shouldn't eat the bad flesh
I'm not gonna do it
you can't make me
I know what I'm about and I ain't about
bad flesh
I eat the good stuff uh-huh
I think that good St the actually I ate
good stuff and I had bugs on the brain
I'm to rest my stomach
did he tell me not to eat the bad flesh
or to eat the bad flesh was that a test
oh good God
please father father
consume us all what
we beg huh
consume his flesh who's
my child your child you have grown ah
your flesh is
oh now is the time consume me oh man you
know I'm not in Devore uh
thank you
um look
ah Yee oh man so you said My Flesh was
divine but why am I eating your flesh
then why
I just I'm not I'm not following oh I'm
gonna following as instruct hi
hello who are you yeah I know
hello
it is done
you are like us
now look
look in the mirror I'm pretty sure it's
not gonna be any worse than what I'm
looking at right now
oh
man is it an ominous mirror
hello handsome
how are you doing
okay that was something I ate and that I
I feel bad I feel bad I didn't eat the
bad flesh but I feel bad about that good
game
good game good game gonna gonna haunt me
as I sleep and grow big and strong
maybe people
be gone
welcome to three minutes with your dog
isn't that lovely
I bet this is gonna be great
this isn't three scary games this is
gonna be great three minutes with your
dog who could who could oh
[Music]
aha oh ah I get it now oh thanks pooch
thanks boy
oh man chica you look different
good girl okay
oh
this is fantastic that's a big Frisbee
puppet right hit the blue area I will
I didn't
I'm trying
did it
that I'm the best
Wham
nice
oh oh popster isn't this the best
this is
swell
this is what you call High
hey man
wait a minute
behind I don't know I can't look behind
me oh I Throw That Rock oh
well if I never look behind me nothing
could go wrong
I just want one more throw with my pup
uh oh
everything's fine
everything's fine everything
whoa what is that
it's against nature all right well
that's weird
oh
I missed by that much how's it going
okay all right that's
that's fine
how you doing
good good good oops sorry pop that's
that was wrong where uh oh
boy
okay you got it pop
oh dog
ah interesting
oh
that is concerning
interesting
oh boy
oh
[Music]
Duff my eyes deceive me
oh damn it
um
yes scarecrow getting closer
wait a minute I saw something over there
I saw something
was in the bushes
that scarecrow feels like it's getting a
lot closer I don't know about you guys
damn it I'm goofing that
everything's good
everything's great
everything is good
everything is great
everything is great nope nope
everything
oh wait a minute
oh
oh boy I can't turn around anymore well
good I didn't want to
I really didn't want to
hi puppy thank you well
um oh no no no no no no
[Music]
foreign
something
[Music]
well done got me good
um I feel bad about everything and uh
hopefully I go play with Chica and she
will have mercy on me when the dog
Uprising begins so thank you and as
always
we're moving on it's not over yet
we're moving on
welcome to
there's something
how about an old screamer in a while
haven't had just a classic
I haven't had a classic screamer in a
little bit
[Laughter]
I'm gonna add one of those in a bit so
uh we're gonna go into this there's
something in the woods there's also
something in the settings apparently but
we're not gonna worry about that right
now we're gonna go into the woods
cheers
[Applause]
I knew I thought there was giant butts I
need to get coffee
that that I do
and that I will I you got coffee in here
anybody
uh oh
man that was really in my ears
to go to the counter and pay for it
first should I oh
blood it looks fresh and there's so much
of it I should investigate this and
follow the trail to the back room
or not
oh my God
yeah or not oh I did a dead body with no
head Jesus Christ what in the hell
happened here his uh his head his head
was detached with Force sweet God we
could have done this I have to find out
I have no survival Instinct I would die
instantly in a horror movie which I'm in
basically hey if you go outside for a
smoker's home Mills make sure maybe you
should go in pairs because I recently
heard some weird sounds in the woods
they were Almost Human
probably just wolves around lines but
still be careful outside listen to The
Sounds who thanks boss I guess when I
find the dead employee I just take up
the mantle of Clerk and I die oh I have
a gun you better watch out
you better not cry
you better not talk I'm telling you why
stash is hunting
again it's a good thing is
well Dolly gee what in the [__] wait for
me
don't have fun without me
I'll be right there oh
boom
boom boom boom bang boom no reloads
ah anyway not when you're dreaming
buying a boom bang boom
are you all right
are you okay
dead body with no eyes
oh my God something tore his stomach and
his eye well my God this guy is full of
bullet holes someone shot him up oh I
can't believe it it was such a spicy you
know who'd have thought whatever did
this it's not human most likely a gun oh
well ah let me give you a let me give
you a parting salute
all right
um
I can't see now I can
seems to be blood right there
hmm
well I'm not gonna wait around guys
I oh red dab ran out of bullets right at
the moment I
died well oh
oh you report all this [__] I'm right
here in my car
boom bang boom not today
I God help me God can't help me now I've
eaten body it's half it's this
half-eaten body is half eaten
anyway I better get out of here good
thing there's only one skin walker
yes I like running at full speed through
the darkness
hmm well seems things seem to be going
well
hmm
looks like I'm gonna make it out in one
piece
I like those poor bastards over there
yeah they died
la la la into my I'm I'm police
that explains a lot
[Applause]
and I survive
of course I do all right well I
I expected death and I exceeded it so
thank you and that was great thank you
for making it you're welcome for playing
and thank you for making it
Michael adamski
[Music]
thank you for watching this three scary
games video You Shall Live Another Day
the uprising is starting but don't you
worry for your soul is saved
well
for now